so first of all congratulations on
getting the cage music you call the
family nice to meet you too how does
husband find out about being part of the
Hall of Fame how did you find out it was
through a phone call
forget the president of Karras Allen
week that completely took me by surprise
oh yeah yeah I had no idea what he was
calling about he had we'd never met we
had never spoken and before I knew who
he was but we had never had a
conversation and it's that me and him as
I was saying that he'd like to talk to
me about an opportunity mm-hmm for the
Junos so I was thinking it's been a
while since I've been on the Junos
probably over 20 years and so I figured
it may be because I was putting on a new
record maybe he wanted me to present an
award or something like I'd know no
inkling no idea no so you know in your
mind when you think about your career
and accolades and how they relate to the
things that you've done is is that
something that you I guess I guess you
just didn't expect it you don't you
don't think about that thing go this is
something that I would like to be well
of course it's something that I was
aware is out there yeah you know it's
not something I don't think an artist
should be trying to set their goals
towards winning awards or being inducted
into Hall of Fame's I think the artist
should stay focused on their work and be
truthful and honorable to their work and
give it you know 110% and and then the
water will find its own level and I'm
just very very humbled and very grateful
that look hey man it's the coolest thing
I'm gonna be in a Hall of Fame of
Canadian music it's like you can't get
better than that yeah yeah so you know
after you said it's about 20 years since
you've been part of the Junos you're
thinking about what it would be like
stepping out onto this daisy longer yeah
probably
it's definitely 20 years and I haven't
performed on the Junos since the 80s
yeah so your question was I have my
thing are you thinking about what's
gonna be like to be out on a stage
I'm trying not to think about it too
much because I won't fall asleep at
night and I don't sleep well generally
anyways so
it would be you know good recommendation
for me just to not overthink this whole
process and really live the moment I
don't know how you feel about when
important things happen to your life or
significant things sometimes they just
pass by in a blur right and my intention
is really to just feel authentic Lee
that moment and react in the moment of
it but I'm certainly keen and very
excited about singing scene performing
and how are you feeling about getting
out on the road again sharing your meat
your music your new music with crowds
all over well all of this is like
incredible this is a great season in my
life right now yeah if we're in a book I
don't know what chapter I'm in but it's
a great chapter to be reading for me I'm
really enjoying it because I stepped
away from the music business and in 1998
as a recording artist and as a touring
artist and here we are 20 years later
and I'm embarking on this pretty big
project to go out across the arenas in
Canada from one side to the other and
I'm just very grateful and humbled that
that my fans still want to see me you
know I never took that for granted
mm-hmm
when you decided to step away you know
you want to spend time with your family
you want to be there what other thing
now now that you're hitting the road
again getting into the press cycle again
getting everything again they they think
it's great then they were encouraging me
for the last five or six years they were
saying that I ought to do something
again but my youngest is 14 actually he
just turned 15
two days ago yeah so the time is a
little more conducive now with the other
I've got four kids so my three oldest
are doing their own things pursuing
their own dreams they're out of the
house right now and I missed them missed
them terribly yeah but it affords me the
opportunity to go back and do what I did
in my other life yeah
my my family and my kids are excited
they're gonna come on the road for the
tour as much as they can one has a full
time job in New York City so she can't
yeah but I'm gonna write and ask to see
if we can get her as long as long
holidays as possible nice doesn't really
feel like like another life for you it
feels like it's an extension of that
other life but that other life was so
long ago yeah that let's say it's a
reincarnation so there's still parts of
the old life that I'm remembering I mean
I know what it's like to do interviews
and I I remember it and and I'm an older
man now you know I was I was a kid when
I went all it all started for me and in
that time did you take an away from the
spotlight you know you were running an
indie label as well you were doing a lot
of other things what what have you taken
from that time away from being at home
that's helped you grow and mature and
and be ready for this new chapter that
you right now well I think that you know
life is life is discovery and learning
and absorbing and making mistakes you
know we're often defined by our
successes but I actually think that were
more defined by how we react to
adversity and setbacks and you know my
life's had its ups and downs there's
been things that have affected me in a
negative way and and I believe that I'm
just I think we're more seasoned as we
get when we go along how old are you
anthers n you're 37 so you're a few
chapters earlier than me quite a few
just you've got a couple kids yeah you
got a couple kids so I'm sure that
you're doing all that you want to do and
with your career and they're trying to
balance your home life and stuff with
with you with your family but when when
you're a few few chapters later on in
the book I think the experiences that
you've gone through is it's just gonna
help you just makes it's kind of like I
don't drink wine but it's probably like
wine to probably taste better but I
don't know because I don't drink right
so the music that you're putting out now
is that stuff that's been in your brain
for years and years and years or these
ideas that you've had that have been
bubbling up for a long time
with songwriting has been in my DNA in
my brain since I was a little boy so
I've always before was running music I
was writing stories so I've always been
a writer I suppose but all the songs
that I wrote for this EP are songs that
I wrote in 2018 yeah so they are not
songs from five or six years ago they're
not old tapes that I reworked they're
just completely brand new songs and they
actually all speak to how I feel in the
present tense and that's I think that
that's special so what is the
significance of dreaming time again of
just that title well on a macro version
so it's not just my perspective on it
it's about anyone that's felt like
they've wanted to do something and
they've put it put it off for a while or
they haven't had the right chance to do
it and they want to take that dive into
the water maybe not knowing if it's cold
or hot but still want to go for it and
do it in my particular case it was
reliving all the dreams that I had as a
kid about making music and going on the
road and playing songs for people and
feeling that euphoria that that music
has always given me ya know I mean so
blessed to live my life with music
you